it's PS plus extra and premium time once
again the mid-month update that piles on
more games onto you than is humanly
possible to play I'm Adam hello there
I'll take you through all 23 of the new
games added and the 37 that are leaving
this week too we've got a lot to get
through so let's crack on humanity is
the new game of the month a Puzzler in
which we play as an Angelic dog guiding
lost humans into the light the humans
need constant directions but follow
orders perfectly if you played Pikmin
there's a sense of that here but the
real inspiration is Lemmings mindless
beings that need to be pointed in the
right direction constantly we wonder
each stage freely and place commands on
the ground for people to follow and as
you'd expect the complexity builds up
over time like another group of people
known as the others arrives both sets of
humans can co-exist but not always
fighting will occur which leads to
weapons and some Star Wars inspired neon
glow stick battles between the blue of
humanity and the red of the others also
confirmed is a the stage Creator
allowing all players around the world to
build missions and publish them online
this should hopefully see the game
become more than a one and done
experience a more of a monthly return to
visit the new content humanity is on PS4
PS5 psvr and psvr too so wherever you
play Humanity has you covered the game
which is going to get a lot of love this
month is Ratchet and Clank Rift apart
the action platformer's first appearance
on the PS5 from 2021 the selling point
of Rift apart was the ability to use
dimensional tears to Traverse the world
and completely jump in between realities
seamlessly this time around Ratchet and
Clank meet another lombax and along with
her sidekick team up to battle against
the usual you know an evil emperor
trying to take over the entirety of
reality Ratchet and Clank Rift apart is
packed with an arsenal of weapons that
range from typical plasma blasters to
dropping entire T-Rexes from Horizon
zero Dawn on your enemies heads any
Dimension is reachable in Rift apart oh
and it's a really fun Platinum too
definitely want to play another great
game is watchdog's Legion a sprawling
open world of tech and Espionage set in
London no less we must build up a
resistance of Fighters to take on those
in charge of the city and to do this
anyone we see can be playable from a
construction worker to a typical
bartender we are able to recruit almost
anyone we see by helping them with a
mission they'll become selectable and
with them comes their own skills and
abilities from renowned fist fighters
who are handing a brawl to tech savvy
James Bond types while in London you'll
be hacking drones deploying spider bots
and using a type of invisibility cloak
with an online mode and a city to
explore I highly recommend Watchdogs
Legion May sees not one not two but
three Tomb Raider games added to the
collection an entire Trilogy no less
starting with 2013's reboot to Lara's
tale where she is much younger and new
to the life of Tomb raiding and on her
way to becoming a hardened Survivor the
gameplay Loop in all three of these
games is simple platform and puzzle
solving and taking out threats and
getting through countless QuickTime
events the Tomb Raider Definitive
Edition includes all DLC and the PS4
version holds an 85 rating on Metacritic
then Lara returns in Rise of the Tomb
Raider this is set inside Buria and
introduces survival elements this game
also includes a psvr game mode and
brings online multiplayer to the masses
in particular check out endurance mode
as it mixes up expectations you and a
friend must survive the bitter
Wilderness managing your hunger and
warmth and crafting your weapons it's
quite an interesting change to the
series and finally shadow of the Tomb
Raider and Lara is becoming the
all-conquering badass you was meant to
be this time the temperature is a little
better here in a Mayan jungle Shadow
innovates Again by introducing the
largest Hub area to a Tomb Raider game
ever and introduces underwater
environments and deep tunneling systems
like never before whoa hold on a sec
check this game out a must play no less
Bus Simulator 21. I'm not sure about you
but I've never spent money on a Sim
emulator game like this here we get to
be the bus driver we've always wanted to
be and be the chauffeur people need I'm
kinda tempted by it anyone else no just
me the horror game of the month is the
evil within two only last month the
first game was added to PS plus extra
and now here's the sequel the gameplay
Loop remains intact with an exploration
of horror-filled corridors and then a
fight or flight situation with traps
stealth or all our action being options
this time we are searching for our
daughter which really does sound like a
nightmare perfect another game added
last month was Dishonored and this month
here are the sequels Dishonored death of
the outsider and Dishonored 2. The
Outsider is a standalone DLC as we play
a killer for hire with many characters
from the original returning with one key
quest in mind can they take down the
outsider who so happens to be a god-like
being Dishonored is famed for its mutty
approach level design which makes almost
every playstyle possible from using
witchcraft like abilities to stay in the
shadows to reaching a Target by running
and running taking down anyone who
stands in your way Dishonored 2 on the
other hand lets us play as empress Emily
or the OG Royal protector corvo atano
tasked with taking back the throne from
Emily's Auntie both games have a Critic
score above 80. so well worth playing
but wait there's more Conan Exiles is
here on PS plus extra and a warning is
needed to anyone who plays around family
you'll start the game in the buff which
means there's shlongs everywhere be
careful Conan Exiles is an online
multiplayer game all about survival but
unlike other survival games this is the
world of Barbarians and sorcery after
building a home it's time to hunt for
food and survive freezing temperatures
before the real game mode begin
searching for loot in dungeons sakuna of
rice and ruin is next on PS4 it's like a
side-scrolling genshin impact in which
we learn about agriculture and also
fight mythical beasts weird right after
each rice crop is complete secondary
levels up and allows them to take on
more difficult demons following on from
the Wolfenstein games we got last month
we have another one Wolfenstein Young
Blood the iconic first person shooter
this time puts us in the boots of BJ's
twin daughters Jess and self to have a
feeling their dad who's been missing for
19 years is still alive but those pesky
World War II Germans keep getting in the
way next time Asia on the PS5 a
fast-paced combat RPG that is the months
Dark Souls inspired game although time
Asia takes this in a different direction
with plague weapons that recruit the
opposition we can also shapeshift to a
raven during battles and everything is
focused on upgrades and the constant
pursuit of power this is Lake it's a
story driven tale about a 40-something
year old moving out of the city and
going back to her little Hometown it's
the slowest paced game on this list and
explores relationships from back in the
1980s as you hand deliver mail
brainworld is next a 2d retro platformer
in which we sneak to catch our prey and
also elude those who want to eat us rain
world has an evolving ecosystem which
sees different animals become part of
the world and sometimes knowing if their
friend faux or food can be difficult
roon Factory 4 special is next a crop
growing monster raising food cooking
fish-catching life simulator we play as
a character with amnesia and build a
homestead while waiting for those
memories to return imagine if Animal
Crossing was crossed with a retro Legend
of Zelda game and you've kind of summed
this one up unlike this one story of
Seasons friends of Mineral Town it's
another take on that but without the
action it's more about maintaining
relationships whilst harvesting crops
and mining for resources and finally on
extra this month is soundfall on both
PS4 and PS5 a Dungeon Crawler with the
looter shooter elements the thing that
makes this one special is its
rhythm-based matching the beat while
you're fighting is the core mechanic and
it's surprisingly fun too after all that
good news it's time for the bad part of
the month knowing that some games will
be leaving on May 16th so you've got
less than a week to finish playing the
following games and there's a scary
amount to get through Marvel Spider-Man
and Spider-Man game of the year editions
are leaving as two are two Batman games
Arkham City and Arkham Asylum Injustice
2 is another DCT title going away and
the Lego Harry Potter collection is off
too and the sublime Resident Evil is
leaving on May 16th as well and I shall
Blitz through all the others that are
leaving this month flat out 4 Total
Insanity TT Isle of Man Ride On The Edge
too Tour de France 2021 on PS4 and PS5
graveyard keeper Deadlight director's
cut home front the revolution Kona this
war of mine the little ones shenmue 3
relicta Red Faction gorilla remastered
Mighty number nine wind bound Metro last
Light Redux Metro 2033 Redux Kingdom
Come Deliverance MX vs ATV all out
ballon Wonderland Star Ocean First
departure R Left Alive day one edition
chocobar's Mystery Dungeon Kronos before
the ashes NBA 2K playground 2 how to
survive storm warning Edition pixel
piracy last day of June Virginia deep
fall chapters and Pathfinder King maker
37 games are leaving PS plus extra in
premium but don't worry worry too much
because eventually those games will most
likely return at some point and finally
it's on to the premium games of May 2023
there's four in total siphon filter
Logan's Shadow is a PSP game that tries
to make siphon filter more like Splinter
Cell blade dancer lineage of light again
a PSP game this time an RPG that is
quite similar to Final Fantasy Pursuit
force is a gang fighting game all about
controlling the local city and
Ghostbusters the video game remastered
lets us join the team and we'll
constantly have you singing who are you
gonna call after playing we did it 23
games added this month what a huge month
GG for getting through this video Until
the End I'm Adam you're awesome my voice
is killing I'll see you next time